it never occurred to me that I would
even be considered for it I mean I had
not done anything dramatic and it's one
thing to do commercials and it's
fabulous
but it isn't how do you become a
character how do you break down a script
how do you delve into that whole thing
and realize the the relationships of
each of the of the characters and you
know how do you do that and so I was
very fortunate and having Alfred
Hitchcock and his wife Alma as being my
drama coaches she was a very well-known
editor she was always the one who was in
the background and always giving very
sage advice to him and he listened very
very carefully what we did up in Bodega
Bay was mostly the outdoor scenes and
because what he wanted was control of
the lighting when so these sets were
brought back into the studio so that he
would have control to make his leading
ladies look absolutely fabulous only
after I had done this very extensive
screen test that was three days with Bob
Burks as the DP Boyle did the set Edith
had did a whole a whole wardrobe for me
we did scenes from Rebecca notorious and
catch and catch a thief three entirely
different women and they flew Martin
balsam in to be my leading man and after
that had after the screen test had been
a sin assembled and they all I guess
everybody at Universal watched it they
invited me to dinner at Chasen's
restaurant and
hich and his wife Alma and Lew Wasserman
who was then head of Universal joined us
and he placed this very beautifully
wrapped package small package in front
of me from Gump's in San Francisco and I
opened it and it was this perp in three
birds in flight and it's made of gold
and seed pearls and I looked at it and
he said we want you to play Melanie
Daniels in the road well I was literally
blown away because it had never occurred
to me that I would be given that kind of
an accolade and I was asked to sit in on
meetings with the cinematographer with a
set designer with Edith Head who I
adored and all the different Herman's
citroen who was you know doing the music
and so that's how I acquired this
education in motion in making motion
pictures it would have taken me 15 years
to learn what I learned there and the
way that he directed me was so
interesting because I we would talk
about the scene and we would talk about
the characters and the personalities of
the characters and but there was very
very little actual instruction about how
I should do it I mean it was it was so
it was done in such a subtle way that
and I think most of the actors who were
worked with Hitchcock woods that would
say the very same thing and of course
the fabulous Jessica Tandy the scene
where she has driven down to find out
what's going on with the birds and she
goes to see a neighbor and she finds him
horribly murdered by the birds and she
comes back to the house hysterical and
so I I bring her you know a tray of tea
and you know whatever and hitch said now
I want you to play this in a very [ __ ]
way and I went
okay that's fun
so I did and and then we went on to
other scenes and that sort of thing so
in the meanwhile that was being edited
and when it was assembled and Jessica
watched it with hitch and at the end of
it she turned to him and she said
nobody's going to like that girl and you
know what hitch listen to her back came
the set meanwhile that had been put away
in storage and you know we were on to
other things and and the set was put
back and so you have the same movie the
same scene the same dude actors the same
set the same everything and I did it in
a very kind of caring way and you know
it was one of the best lessons that I
ever has the best teaching lesson is
that how how an actress can change the
whole picture by the way that that one
scene is done it was an it was very
inspiring for me